So now let's get further into what's going
on with Eugene. Carol, I told you yesterday
that once again, Donald Trump has been accused
of rape. I don't know how many total rape
and sexual assault allegations this makes.
I read one piece that says Eg and Carol is
number 16. Uh, another that says she's number
13. Others say 17. I don't know what the answer
is, but the latest accuser is Eg and Carol
who says that Donald Trump raped her in new
New York City department store in the late
1990s she goes into specific and very explicit
detail about it. Somehow this garnered very
little corporate media coverage. Nothing I
was able to find on the Sunday morning talk
shows two days ago. Only a little bit of coverage
yesterday, Joe Biden standing too close to
a woman apparently deserved a ton of coverage,
but yet another accuser who says the president
of the United States raped me gets relatively
little coverage and unfortunately, and this
leads to what I was talking about earlier,
that accuser aging Carol has now started to
receive death threats as was described to
a CNN reporter yesterday when Joe Biden stands
too close to a woman, Joe Biden is the problem.
According to the right wing Trumpists when
a woman accuses Donald Trump of rape, the
woman who says she was raped is the problem
to those exact same Trumpists. And this is
why there's a fundamental problem in fighting
people for whom this is just sport. I talked
about this last week. We can't stoop to their
level because it's an immoral level, but at
a certain point we also need to win and take
them out of power. So look at the double standard
with the Al Franken and the Roy Moore situations.
By the way, Roy, Roy water's running again
and we'll talk about that soon. Maybe later
on this week when Al Franken was involved
in an arguably tasteless joke involving of
female reporter and a flak jacket, Republicans
demanded that Al Franken resign and frank
and did resign after even some Democrats said
she should probably go and he resigned his
seat from the u s senate.
In retrospect, there are many people now on
the left who say, you know, given all the
stuff that Republicans have excused, it's
not to just totally clear that Al Franken
should have resigned, but he did resign. Meanwhile,
you had Republican candidate for us Senate
from Alabama, Roy Moore, who was accused of
multiple instances of sexual assault, including
against teenage girls, and he received 48.3%
of the vote from Alabama voters. He lost by
under 22,000 votes. Democrats have plenty
of scumbags, but the rules are not even remotely
the same for how Republicans and Democrats
handle this stuff. Who was defending Anthony
Wiener, a Democrat who is caught multiple
times sexting with various women. Now, I don't
even remember what I believe. One of them
was under age, uh, who was defending John
Edwards, a Democrat for his mistress fiasco,
the details of which, I don't even remember
now. I'm sure you can find someone in a country
of 340 million people.
Certainly there were some people defending
Anthony Wiener and John Edwards, but it was
few and far between Newt Gingrich's affairs
while his wife had cancer, Donald Trump's
affairs and 1516, 17 sexual assault allegations.
Roy Moore, serial accused sex assault or gets
48% of the vote. How do we defeat people who
have no rules and see this only as the sport
of wins and losses and not as real people
and real life? I don't know the answer. Okay.
But at a certain point, we've got to start
winning. Uh, and this is, you know, I'm not
playing coy and saying, Oh damn, Democrats
are victims of their own morality and upstairs
there's plenty of scumbags, uh, who are in
power. There's plenty of scumbags who defend
those in power, who do bad things on the left,
but they're playing by different rules at
this point in time. So I don't know what the
answer is, but it's abundantly clear that
Trump supporters are not going to be influenced
by allegation after allegation after allegation.
Uh, and one way or another, this is a guy
who has to be removed, but remember that this
is a symptom, okay. The fact that evangelicals
voted for him, even though he goes against
everything, they claim to stand for the fact
that they are totally unwilling to just say,
Hey, this has to stop. This is not a good
guy. Uh, it is not something that is going
to go away if and when Donald Trump is removed
from office or leaves office in a year and
a half or five and a half years. And this
is a bigger sort of course inning of the dialogue
coarsening of morality that we are going to
at some point need to deal with and I genuinely
don't know what the answer is. If you have
ideas, let us know. We'll have a question
about this. A poll question on the David Pakman
show Instagram page later on today or maybe
later this week. That's at David Pakman show
on Instagram. And while you're there, follow
me. I'm at David Pakman on Instagram. Quick
break back after this to talk about
which centrist Democrats should be the top
two priorities to primary with more progressive
challengers. That's coming up next, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com